yeah hello and welcome to this video or
playing aqaba in the house yeah going to
slay this yeah I know it's boring this
line again and see what happens I mean
okay against this rating you should
probably should try it a little bit more
okay but still um night to each other
was a check keep forgetting my own my
own stuff should be seven or queen
should before I could before a little
bit on the slow side I don't quite
remember how this line actually works
the Queen's now we'll move just wonder
where exactly no it does not move okay
so with some plain father for the
development advantage shown so sorry the
phone let's see my develop my
development is not great it really isn't
look HD one definitely dangerous how how
do i how do I play here the Queen trade
would be good I don't know if I can get
it l
this should be same group inching warned
castles and he has the discovery and
this is the thing that discovered attack
on the e-file is extremely extremely
tough extremely tough to meet
they exit plane is more probably i don't
really see anything else jana castles
should be five and i'm in trouble I
think I go with this rookie agent
gaining a tempo if if I'm here take him
and if he takes with the night I can't
capsule because I have Queen c4 check
always so we will probably take with the
rook and be okay with being a pawn up
but now I'm not checking me and now I
can get out of the middle at least so
that didn't go too well but we get half
of my do shoot me okay Nevel anyway
after you always have to fight g2 Hanks
and maybe maybe 94 or something this
King is also it's not perfect to save
them then it might might still be
playable I mean 94 i prevented it's
probably a good move twin b6 around the
corner maybe we should be formed now
let's do it there is going to be six
after which i probably take and click
the age
[Music]
Queen should be six i also have Quincy
for maybe and clean the fire to the
queen bee six looks very natural here
maybe something else I don't know Queen
a fall or something yeah okay so Queen B
6 no does that take
normal walking be one fails due to the
Queen caption okay now there is no ch
unfortunately I would be nice would be
nice to have I need to need to do
something with my back Rankin probably
this one we should age six o'clock
teenage form I want to trade Queens
quite obviously as king as more of a
problem than mine rook c8 he now has
rusev okay
okay I'm getting one bad hmm not so easy
to play this thing i'm somewhat active
him g2 how does he come with that it
doesn't have a bishop move really a good
one looks like i might bring g2 they can
check check his queen d1 kanji to maybe
this one just being annoying chick I'm
warning check check
OOP do you want to cringe it too badly
so we would make a draw now he's a space
acclaim I don't particularly want to
draw check check aah no no aah ok have
this one which overlooked initially ok I
can't do it again ok I probably
shouldn't make the draw any way any way
to avoid it and it is hanging this one I
can still check me oh forgot about that
move completely check check check check
ah friggin pre-move know haha come on
this is so logical it's just you know
yeah check check laughs e46 on time I
have AI should just take a draw one you
know volume those kind of situations but
I never want to really
yeah in here here was definitely in big
trouble there's this chance now create
and then IG highest wow wow check
yeah something like that you can take
here be sure to z 5j yeah that's very
good of course so that wouldn't would
have done the trick until probably I
should take first something known as a
chicken yeah i mean i'm worth the
evidence i somehow put up a decent fight
and really got a good position again not
again but yeah it was totally
flourishing Jenks yes I will never have
something there check check check yeah
now it gets 5 12 seconds insisting yeah
this is here pretty move from pre move
this you know because very hey I was
thinking it would take some and that was
a bloody pre-move mistake twin f6 is
draw the king at six is a draw h5 is
utterly ridiculous but it's a privilege
yeah and I wonder actually was probably
lost the whole time this is a weird move
but ok 11 seconds a 60s promotes king be
6 is also weird but there are no time 17
yeah and now of course yes it's all pre
move or logical deductions you know hey
there just this end the draw I just go
in front of it and so on but ok it
happens in front 0 ok guys thanks for
watching